don't innocent children deserve to die
yes
because they're in the future are
terrorists
and hateful tourists okay yeah oh
whether they i rather stop them
living now before they grow and have a
weapon
it's simpler oh okay so it's killing
kids is like so if you
if you have the choice you would go into
hospitals where
kids are born and kill them
everyone till the last all gaza
needs to be flit no one there no one
there
it just has you thinking because we see
children being dissipated
we blown to pieces i mean hundreds of
kids just being
you know destroyed so the mindset we
know that there is a clear verse in the
quran killing one innocent human being
doesn't matter jew christian anybody is
as
if you killed all of mankind so what do
you when you see something like this
you know the mindset you know what's
your reaction
this person is probably you know
mentally not well or if he's mentally
well then he needs to be
looked at and western countries need to
know his name and they need to
block his entry into their countries i'm
pretty sure a lot of israelis walk
around freely
in western lands because they get free
passage
but if people who have these views of
walking around freely
i don't i don't see why isis is bad then
why is isis bad they even i don't know
if they said these kind of things they
are bad of course they are bad we don't
agree with them
we have disowned them alhamdulillah by
the grace of allah we have disowned
all people who hold such extremist views
this is extremist extremism of the worst
kind
how can you even think of killing
children it is unbelievable
how what kind of a human heart do you
have are you even a human being
this is the question i ask how can
someone who has blood running through
his veins
and considers himself to be normal talk
like this
this is brainwashing taking place within
the state of israel
where people are being made to think
like this
they are becoming extremists they are
becoming dangerous and these people have
very very dangerous weapons in their
hands and look at look look at what he
said
that all the children of gaza they need
to be wiped out imagine
he becomes the prime minister of israel
imagine if he becomes one of those
uh influential people in israel and i'm
pretty sure there are many people like
that
is this what we are uh is this what we
are trying to promote in the world
is this what we is this why the state of
israel claims
uh that it is a democracy israel the
state of israel respects human rights
if you do then why is this guy free if
he's free
why is he still free who's talking
openly about killing palestinian
children
on screen because he feels the
protection
he needs he knows that nothing's going
to happen he knows he's in israel
if he's in israel i don't know where he
is uh he knows he's not going to be
arrested and reprimanded for this
so this is absolutely crazy
this is this is shocking how people can
talk like this in this day and age
after all the destruction we've had for
the last 30 years what have we learned
from our human experience of the last 30
years where we had
catastrophes of a grand scale we had
iraq war we have afghan war we had
vietnam we have before that we had two
world wars where millions of people died
what have we learned
as humans from those experiences things
seems to be getting worse
unfortunately in some people's mind so
this is this is shocking this is
shocking behavior and this is
brainwashing the worst kind and whoever
is
responsible for this must be held
accountable whoever is responsible for
this kind of problem
this kind of training or this kind of
thought is unbelievable
shocking if a muslim spoke like this
brother eddie if a muslim spoke like
that
from pakistan let's say from palestine
or from morocco
that would be on the news can you
imagine that can you imagine that
yes i mean i i can imagine that i can if
a crazy nutter
a muslim somewhere sitting in a in a
room somewhere
like that i would plaster it all over
the news it would be
everything it would be airlines
everywhere it would it would become
the representation of islam for for a
year
and this is the this is this is the this
is the problem we are facing today
in the world as as a community our voice
is not being heard because we don't have
independent media
we need to have independent media so
that our voices can be heard by the
western masses
not only are not only our own masses but
even the western masses
living in the us in canada in european
lands
in australia people need to hear what
the muslim community has to say on these
things
and that's only possible when we have
independent media when we don't rely on
this so-called mainstream media
that doesn't allow our voices to be
heard yeah that's why we need the media
and influence here's uh trends are set
and even other nations can see other
nations doing good speaking for justice
and maybe this can be a motivation for
them
to get on that bad wagon instead of just
remaining complicit by being silent
so it's very amazing to see
the irish people who are really leading
in this by example i want to get your
take on this bombing of hospitals
or schools of uh sewerage treatment
plants
it is appalling and if you want to know
what the people of palestine you
say that you're speaking on behalf of
people of palestine if you want to know
what the people of palestine want ask
the palestinian farmers
we've seen the most desperate and brutal
violations
of people's right to protest against
injustice against
occupation against the taking of the
very ground from under people
israel is an apartheid state
any of us have been there know that once
you know that it changes you
would you recommend that what was your
take on that you know these are people
obviously know what's going on
you know irish people are strong people
they're brave you know
and these are people of integrity who
are